C
TEOF THEG
EDRA
STORY.
EID TOET OF YOUR
TR OSINGS
SUBJEC
OF.E
ING THRE
O R FAES
INDEPENDENT SCHOOL ADMIN STATE
TRAININSSIONS
ACOL THE BOOKS FOR THEIR
CLASOO
AT THE HEART OF WHATNFSEIS A
LATHRITR
TEACHER
AFFAIRS, THEY'RREQUIREDPLCHCTI.
PART OF THAI
>>O REMEMBER THE
HAVE A BOOK ON HOLOC THAT IF Y
E ON
OPPOSING, THAT HAS-
>> HOWU
HOLOCAUS IIN SAY SHOULD BE
AN OPPF THE HO
HOLOCAT THOUAT WASACTION?S ALMO?
WENOT BEING KED TO HE OPPOSING
TH THAPRLE RTHOSE CERTAIN THINS
YOU'RE BEIEDNG V ON?>> CIVAVERY.
N'TSHE SCHOOL ADMINIST OF
OUILSO IF YOU THINK THE BOOKS
OKAY, THEN LET'S GO WITH IT.
AND WHATEVER HAPPENS, WE WILL
IT TOGETHER.
DID FO CONFUS
CAUSED ADDING E ARE NOT SI THE T
INTOTEE SPONS FOACHERS, BUT AKIT
TIVE A
DRIVING OF THIS  PUSHING SCHOON.
'S A SAWEE
NO
RIGHT NOW.
DGO T. DNEEN TNG
CURRICUMND
>> THE COUNCIL'S DE FEARFUL DO I
MARYLANDS THE LATEST RSEMBARRAST
THERE, IF T
THEN THAT IGNORANCE
IS COMING TO T YO YOU THINK
THISUSONTROL H
IS THE CATALYSFRGNOR
CHANGE IN OURICTWE CAN'T CONTIT.